thank you alejandro well tatev welcome
back to the studio uh you did move to
kansas city uh a year ago you got a new
job at a startup tell us a little bit
about that because it also involves
chess
right so i moved to kansas city in
august of last year so i'm working for a
startup called bright labs they're the
makers of this board called chesap which
is a smart chessboard with a built-in ai
and with this board you can both play
against opponent of different strengths
so we can balance and match with someone
so if you have a kid or a significant
adder you either you try to teach chess
to you can give them an assistance level
so they like eliminate their blunder so
you can balance and match between two
players and you can also play against an
ai opponent you can play on leeches or
chess.com but play it on a physical
board so you can connect it to uh chess
platforms online as well
so how does it look like whenever you
make a move your opponent from leeches
or chess.com of one of the other
platforms makes a move does it show it
on the board um i can show it to you so
okay let's turn this on
all right we have some we have beautiful
colors i love it so it's gonna work the
same way if you play against the ai okay
so let's give you a white let's sure
thank you very much i'll take this
okay
i'll take it
okay so
i'll give you an assistance level i'm
not going to give you the highest one we
have six different assistants level the
highest one you only have
one best move in the position sometimes
too but if you're not a very like a high
rated player you don't need to do that
right you just want to eliminate
mistakes and you want to have options we
haven't started yet so
yeah
so which assistant level i'll give you
assistance level four so four okay okay
and i will you will play against the ai
that's general we also have a built-in
clock okay i like that so you don't have
to actually press the clock it's
automatic so everything is happening
right now from your phone you're setting
everything up on your phone and i also
can give you a touch limit so you can
only touch like two pieces or three
pieces so you're not like touching
everything which is what i did when i
was playing lemon but if you're not sure
if
you have some shame you know
we're talking christian just just be
careful
absolutely no shame give me the maximum
um
okay i'll give you maximum assistance no
no i'm joking give me nothing okay i'll
give you four and i will give you a
touch limit of three and you will play
against the ai so now when you touch the
pieces they will light up according to
strength so greens are your best moves
and
reds are your work so you're telling me
b3
b3 cowboy is worse than e4 yes crazy
right move number one
i don't believe it i'm gonna go b3 i
also didn't give you the highest level
of assistance so you get more greens i
mean more greens and more blues because
it's not the best i mean it's not just
one best move so you're playing against
the ai so when you play on a platform
it'll work the same well just highlight
the move and so i'm just going to make
the ai move okay let's see i'm going to
touch the bishop right now
i don't want to put it on a3 apparently
that's a red that's a blunder it seems
like if you let go it's
i'm going to go to b2 all right knight
to c6 yeah this is a lot easier than
playing let's see if i remember
the ai moves
let's see if i remember my theory here
knight to
knight to e5 i'm pretty sure his path so
i'm going to go knight i like the two
red squares too
oh the knight and three
okay let's take this i feel we got to
help christian here i don't know if
there's any helping question
it's too late it's all ready it's too
late yeah it's already i tried during
the utd days but uh decades ago oh
let's see i think i'm doing great
it's still great i'm not doing anything
so i'm just doing this so that's good
kicking you away let's go back so it's
going to go d4 oh my goodness
christian yeah he's squeezing me yeah
develop your pieces hide your kings
yes
what engine stockfish okay got it so you
can also use a different level of ai oh
look what
boom
so
one of the things we have to tell our
audience is that
christian of course is getting paid to
be a lobbyist for it
because he's playing so badly he's
making the computer look so good and
it's not just a playing platform right i
believe that it comes with lessons and
ways to learn the game if you want to
improve so it makes not just a great
gift for yourself but people that are
trying to get into the game exactly
exactly yeah boys i'm stuck
you moved your knight from b1 to e3 and
it only took you like six turns but this
is the problem you've got a problem
there's a lot of problems
my goodness all right let's try to go
crazy i mean to follow what alejandra
was saying i am the director of chess so
i'm actually putting together lesson
content and leveling is our ambassador
and he is the ambassador professor nice
what's the yeah i think of his game
today
uh i haven't looked at it with this ai
so as a professional chess player or a
former professional chess player how
cool is it to have a job that requires
you to use all your chess skills tatev
did you just call me a former professor
she used to get a top three in
tournaments yeah
on come on ancient history we're talking
about right now
no i mean it's very nice and my company
is very supportive of me so i have
several months to play chess so when i'm
here playing a tournament like i don't
have to do anything work related i just
completely focus on my tournament very
nice so for example u.s championships i
offer a draw vacation okay i offer a
draw guys very nice very gentle can you
ask
whether they want the draw
some kind of a checkmate a checkmate
okay i'll i'll show you a nice check
yeah yes
and then we will see what happens but
is there yes there is a maze
that is the ugliest checkmate i've ever
seen
exhibition match or no exhibition hey
they paid me a lot of money for this
okay so how do the people online
who have viewed this how do they order
is it available when will it be
commercially available oh it's pre-order
right now that we're going to start
shipping in june so it's on that website
on pridelabs.com
you can see the website right there
pre-order on brightlaps.com with the y
and it's uh it's a local initiative
missouri initiative yes exactly
well thank you that's very entertaining
it looks like a great product thank you
for a form of trust flair
not bad for a former professional jet
player right not bad at all using her
chess skills to uh bring amateur players
into the game and it is a nice way by
the way because for significant others i
mean genie and rex used to play against
each other but when rex started winning
you know a lot
now genie can
fight back with this product and i like
the assistance levels where it doesn't
just completely tell you what the
password is it gives you like this gamma
where you can decide choices choices you
put your finger on it and it goes here
here you go okay okay i don't want to
deal with this one ah
very very nice